Speaker 1: If you thought Donald Trump's 2016
promises about a wall on the southern border
that Mexico would pay for a beautiful new health
care plan ending the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
and all of that stuff was unrealistic if you
thought that was farfetched. The stuff that Trump
is increasingly promising if he were to become
president in 2024 is even more outrageous. And it
includes flying cars. I know. I know. It's truly
a stunning thing, but that's what Trump is talking
about. There's an exclusive Politico article.
Trump calls for Contest to create futuristic
Freedom Cities, which says modern cities and
flying cars might sound like the makings of an
episode of The Jetsons, where a fictionalized
family flew around in Orbit City for former
President Donald Trump. It's the foundation of a
new set of futuristic policy proposals. In a video
set to be released Friday, Trump will call for a
quantum leap in the American standard of living.
He already talked about those freedom cities
during his CPAC speech, which was pretty
unhinged and basically sort of like a camp for
homeless people. And Trump also is talking about
technological elements. In another political
article, it sort of expands on the flying cars
idea. Trump calling for massive investment
in vertical takeoff and landing vehicles,
also known as flying cars. There is something
really interesting here. Now, first and foremost,
the right loves to say that the left promises
unrealistic things. The things the left promises
are only unrealistic insofar as Republicans are
unwilling to actually fund them and insist that
they're not things worth, worth, worth doing,
including trying to get everybody health care
or whatever the case may be. One of the really
interesting thing about flying cars is that
it's very easy to visualize it when you talk
about, well, we're going to work hard to change
the way that we power our homes and cars. So it's
increasingly from wind and sun rather than. Well,
listen, you've I flipped on a light bulb. I
don't know. It turned on. It doesn't feel that
different. If the source changes from being coal
to being solar or whatever the case may be. And
because it's less visual, it also doesn't really
sound that worthwhile to put any money into it.
Okay. So flying cars, extraordinarily visual.
The other thing is that Trump does have this
tendency to get obsessed with something without
really understanding it. You might remember where
there were a few speeches Trump gave, I think
this was in 2020 where he became focused on
going to Mars, even if he called it Nars.
Speaker 2: The United States will be the
first nation to land an astronaut or NAS.
Speaker 1: Okay, I remember it like it was
yesterday. So Trump does get fixated on
some of this futuristic stuff as well.
But the flying cars, the inclusion of flying
cars is is pretty damn interesting. Now,
flying cars are also interesting because of the
cultural importance of flying cars. Flying cars
have been a sort of microcosm or emblematic of
the future is now here. And if you look at things
that were written in the thirties and forties
and certainly you look at sci fi in the fifties
and sixties, lots of the things that Arthur C
Clarke wrote about 50 years ago have happened,
satellites and different things. But flying cars
as a sort of ubiquitous staple of the futuristic
society has not developed nearly as quickly as
some imagined that it would. And there's a lot of
different reasons for that. One is if you're going
to have flying cars, they've got to be really,
really safe. And of course, drone technology,
the sort of quadcopter type technology,
might offer some of the redundancies that would
be needed for really safe flying cars. But also,
listen, every time I'm on the highway, there's
someone in the fast lane going 57 while on a cell
phone. I don't know that I want to put those
people in the air anytime soon. And so until
the self-driving technology really matures,
flying cars aren't going to be happening any
time soon. But the inclusion of it is certainly
interesting. So a lot of cultural stuff to talk
about when we talk about flying cars. And it is
really interesting. Trump promising flying cars
between 2025 and 2029. That is not a realistic
promise, as I'm sure most of you realize.